ladies and gentlemen welcome to Tim
Dylan is going to hell this was
originally know what you said Tim
Dylan's going to hell [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
leave it like this ladies and gentlemen
I apologize I apologize ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the info wars
podcast my name is Tim Dylan ladies and
gentlemen welcome to my favorite murder
Yaffe's ladies and gentleman welcome to
two dub queens ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the last podcast on the left
ladies and gentlemen welcome to Tuesdays
with stories ladies a job and walk with
a fighter in the can ladies and
gentlemen welcome to whiskey ginger
three two one and we're live you know
what that one is
ladies and gentlemen welcome to chapo
Trap House welcome to come town welcome
to uh [ __ ] I'm blanking out welcome to
our revisionist history those
pretentious [ __ ] welcome to the Monday
morning podcasts welcome to tinfoil hat
it is a Tim Dylan show folks the episode
was supposed to be a patreon episode we
recorded a killer [ __ ] episode and I
said you know what we're gonna put it
out for everybody we got another Pig on
a killer patreon episode coming so
patreon people don't be don't be miffed
don't be small-minded and angry at this
there should be more people subscribing
to the patreon we've got some really
great content on there and it's only
gonna get better we're also gonna change
that Ben I don't like that little up top
that I do about the patreon every week
yeah I wanted to just feel a little
different it feels too so I'm gonna do
another one where I I you know okay I
just don't like it it feels - I don't
know but I don't know it just feels like
it's physical
and people over the head yeah I got what
I mean yeah I know the people are stupid
but we at least got to show them a
little bit of respect well we try to get
in there and take their money you know
what I mean we can't be too we can't
expect too much but we can't also expect
to look you know we gotta we got to go
in there and really figure out a way to
get it get it from them you know so this
is a great episode you'll enjoy it
it's gonna be it's an hour late already
or two hours late and there's you're
gonna run your mouth about it but really
really shut the [ __ ] up think about it
think about life and shut the [ __ ] up
goodbye hi I'm Timmy the trash can and I
love trash so good instead of throwing
your trash on the floor won't you please
give it to me
thank you for considering your fellow
patrons sit down and making everybody
nervous standing around ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the Tim Dylan show
patreon episode exclusively for patreon
members five dollars a month entitles
you to one extra episode of the program
and also unlimited access to the
archives how many episodes do we have
for the men German a hundred and forty
five a hundred and forty-five archived
episodes stop asking for the one where I
talk about the CEO of NBC Universal that
one was destroyed you don't get to hear
that they paid me three grand and they
would they held that money over my head
and I [ __ ] took that down immediately
to get paid but it's still a great deal
get in now folks twenty dollars a month
you're a Rothschild member you're the
top tier no that is not a Jewish
conspiracy reference they are a wealthy
family it means that you support the
show you have a little extra income not
only do you get all the other men
purrs I mean you get all the other
benefit you get all the other members if
you're a Rothschild member we give you
other members
we're selling slaves human trafficking
know if you are well child remember not
only do you get all the benefits of the
other members but you get exclusive
extra long videos that me and Ben do
desk videos you get to correspond with
us you you get to ask questions we'd use
bonus episodes just for you so join the
patreon and be an American citizen and
even if you're not a citizen you can
still join the patreon I don't give a
[ __ ] how you got here we're joined today
by Kevin tinkin
Kevin's a comedian who lives in Los
Angeles California per se you're
pronouncing it that way uh we're joined
by Jay saver you guys have a podcast -
what is your podcast called brain Jail
brain Jail
it's with this autistic man who's
twisting the knobs it's with Ben and
myself and Jace I like a lot of people
to comment on my podcast you don't get
to like Ben's a producer so they go this
guy's horrible I think he's part of the
show he just doesn't talk every episode
says like two things you don't get that
he's producing the show clearly a
one-man show they're so mad at me for
distributing it to them on time it's
also on my show he has a weird like he
doesn't talk to it usually does he's
like if I'm okay what is the deal with
this he was like I don't even know why
he doesn't talk normally he's prank
calling a hot girl he's been stalking
the other the other not half a brain
jail third 33rd and 35th percent of like
total poundage 50% of poundage on brain
jail Jace a very generous heyguys rather
is Ben Avery mm-hmm raised in taxes now
residing here
in Los Angeles California mm-hmm what is
brain Jail about we talked about growing
up like ex-christian and then just do
like a bunch of like Matt and Shane
secret podcast type bits just making
sure we never have a job in the industry
okay now we started out the podcast
being like this is the summer we all get
cancer right we got to really just put
it in the effort every week right you
know lots of lots of what do they call
that just switching codes codes
switching a lot of code switching lots
of what accents what's the accents do
you feel ever nervous about what you see
on the podcast you ever feel like you'll
lose some of your endorsements is that
you're worried yeah I mean zig zags
you ever sit down with your team and
they're just not happy about the
direction things are heading daily
swarmers been calling us about the ads
yeah oh yeah I will say this about daily
strauber they do need better content
people you know what I mean for Y for
the people that I know you've heard of
what I've heard 8chan is down now
there's no more H oh they took it down I
think it's done where will Ben post is
manifested now that HN is gone Ben write
manifestos no oh yeah I'll tell you this
folks we were all troubled as teenagers
to an extent you know mm-hmm everybody
has that time in your life I never
thought of shooting up my school I never
did I never did and I was bullied yeah
but I never thought I should shoot up
the school
it seems very indirect of how to uh like
get past whatever you got you know
bullied you know in school and you kill
everyone I used to fantasize about
meeting up everybody in my school when
they're not shooting anybody
but everybody like just walk no I
literally cemetery where I beat up
everybody at school and I'd wake up and
feel pretty good I'm trying to think
what my revenge fantasies were
I think I just wanted to [ __ ] everybody
like everyone who bullied me I was just
god I want to suck their dick yes it was
like an interesting way to hate them
plug in a consensual way that word is so
loaded that's all the gay guys that are
real crazy hard on the meat to stuff and
so he's interesting to me because every
gay bar is me - mm-hmm
like Louie took out his dick I'm like
every gay bar before disposing
themselves to each other and grabbing
each other yeah most gay bars it's like
a friendly yeah everybody's like they're
the moral majority yes dude
drag queens used to be hilarious they
used to get up on stage you wanna a.m.
and [ __ ] on every race in the room I
mean like now there's a moral majority
yeah yeah it's odd it's like why are we
you put balls in your mouth why are you
the moral majority in the moral majority
who wants that who wants to be the
[ __ ] church lady
that's correcting that you know
somebody's grammar yeah you want to be
rowdy you want to be fun you want have a
good time life is too short stop holding
every grudge
yeah people it's hard to get scolded by
someone in a wig a little off you know
and it's it just takes me out of it you
know I agree with you I want it I want
to learn I'm here to listen
yeah you know but the the titties are
falling out yeah there's there's a lot
of action going on dude it's fun you
shouldn't be like what people don't
understand about it being like a person
that doesn't live this mainstream life
mm-hmm don't take the worst parts of the
mainstream and incorporate them into
your life yeah like being shitty being
judgmental you know being [ __ ] boring
don't [ __ ] do that
everybody wants the rights to be a piece
of [ __ ] yeah
and they're like you know I ever there
that guy's able to be a piece of [ __ ]
and like finally we got a March
so there we gonna be a total piece of
[ __ ] I'm glad I grew up in a place where
my parents and my friends parents didn't
care about us you know what I mean
and rarely pretended to I'm so grateful
now
yes Drive issues with food yes when I
fed poisoned X was ever taught how to
manage money
no was I prepared for college no I
prepared for life no was I prepared for
intimate relationship sexually or
emotionally no was like given any
self-confidence no self-esteem no
support no was I tall you know as I told
anything positive at any point in my
life no but that being said we had a lot
of fun yeah my parents and my friends
parents we all wanted to just have fun
booze it up eat it up eat it up and
booze it huh the mess trial hood they
weren't into like oh we're gonna prepare
the kids for whatever they were into
like let's get this [ __ ] party
started my friend's mom Barbara Magoo in
the sangria that's real in marby Reds
last name is Magoo Lahan barb would you
sit in the chair
give me some sangria give me some reds
she would drive us around in her car
hotbox it was it rad his dad smoked
Marlboro ultralights like air didn't
even make sense why smoke but they were
fun yeah people how's Barbara doing now
fine do a good man listen they pick you
know you pickle yourself mm-hmm
you know they've probably toned it down
you can't go hard forever you know it's
true I regret that I wasn't a guy that
could handle a pop a drink Ben was not a
guy that can handle a drink nope kind of
do it you know
and I regret that now you can have a
cocktail I can have a drink I can't
smoke a lot of weed right because I'll
just
it'll just be you haven't starts to get
crazy yeah I start singing reggae and
it's it gets real bad I started growing
dreadlocks so choose cultural
appropriate all over ice them all I
start smoking weed early I become a
Jamaican I become a giant if I got get
this far guitar - yeah
get your a bottie boy it's like oh
alright yeah that seems mmm interesting
yeah no I did it just gets to a point
where I'm just I stay in my room for
like six days yeah and I just I just
obsess on you just go to start a start
fights and check cashing place 100% you
start trying to check your cash checks
it don't exist yeah you how many check
cashing places I was exercising cocaine
addict you know how many cash check
cashing places you just see somebody
shout through the bulletproof glass
window with somebody else and go this is
not a check you're trying to cash
something that isn't a check you drew
this I know it has a denomination of
money on it
but they would show up with like
something that said like you're gonna
get this money soon or you owe this
month they didn't like and the people at
the check cashing place would have to be
like this isn't a check and then people
get so mad come on man was in a gold
envelope are you imitating a Jewish
person with that voice yes it's fine a
hundred percent is trying to be certain
of what happened yeah yeah come on man
oh man oh okay I got my passes already
for y'all you can't even catch his
golden check one of the most
embarrassing things that's ever happened
to me is when I first started doing
comedy here's the thing with check
cashing places if you have not cashed a
check before at the check cashing place
they will call whoever wrote the check
yeah and confirm which no bank does like
not that they have ways of verifying it
but check cashing places don't call
right yep and and I needed the money
right away I needed to pay rent I just
done like a gig and I
posited it or not deposited I want to go
cash it at the check cashing place and
they like called the [ __ ] guy who
just wrote me the check and I look like
such a piece of [ __ ] it's like it's
somebody be like Hades he ain't never be
less check cashers yeah I heard the guy
on the other I'd be like why Dylan you
you write them check I said yeah I write
a check what's the problem you know dude
I use check cashing places for very long
oh they're a great place if you can
sometimes you can get money at the like
this save Marling at the grocery store
or whatever but that's no fun either cuz
I'll do the same [ __ ] no check cashing
place I did when I was working at
Letterman and I was in each Bushwick I
went to a very violent check cashing
place and they did the same thing where
they're like is this Letterman and then
everybody was like looking at me like I
was an insane person yeah like I'm
working in TV and I'm at a check cast
yeah they thought I was Paul Shaffer
David Letterman with no sleeves after
[ __ ] get that get that auto ladies and
gentlemen I have told you several times
about the need to relax many of you are
suffering from anxiety much of that
anxiety is is you know appropriate as
many of you are in a directionless and
you really don't know what's coming and
it's gonna be bad and I think we've all
been kind of clear about that and you
know many of you don't know how to
handle it and you're afraid you're gonna
be alone and you're right you're afraid
you're not gonna make connections with
other human beings
you're gonna constantly get in your own
way it's my point many of you have that
fear and that's you know it's based in
reality and you know realistic
understanding of who you are and what
you bring to the table but doesn't mean
that that should be debilitating you
know what I mean you should be able to
get past that you know I don't know any
successful person who dwells exclusively
in reality I don't
they create their own reality okay they
just you know it is what it is they just
you know walls from one topic to the
next and inject their own idea of what
is and isn't true
you don't really it'll go crazy with
facts and figures statistics many of the
most successful people I knew barely
they barely watch the news they barely
have any clue as to what is happening at
any given time they just kind of you
know sashay through life just you know
and I'm telling you right now folks
that's probably the better way to do it
that's probably the way to do it instead
of being hyper focused on reality
reality as they said in the 90s bites
it's the reality of that but how do you
reduce anxiety what do you do you take
klonopin like Jordan Peterson and you
end up in rehab knew not a good look JP
has said some some important things but
I feel from klonopins not to move what
about xanax that's not the move if you
see a little Zen does he look better no
you know got his man I met the guy that
knows his manager recently and it's all
like you're all on Death Watch he was in
European heaven easy annex and his
brother had to like smuggles annex into
Europe and his ass and just cuz little
Xan
suppose that little Xan lit $200,000 on
fire
yeah he's nuts ma'am whatever shoutout
to zan zan Turkey the whole family
I thought little zan and Billy Eilish
with the same person for a very long
time somebody had to explain to me that
they weren't but my point is that you
can't get nuts with the pharmaceuticals
folks it's not the move I know your
parents your boomer parents took you to
the therapist who shove drugs down your
throat we get it they didn't want to
realize their own culpability in your
condition
they didn't want to go do some real
behavioral therapy and work through it
they just paid some doctor to shove the
adderall down your throat when you were
an eighth grade
now you got a real problem you're
scratching yourself your [ __ ] door
stop it this goddamn cat I'm gonna kick
it in its face [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] cat
eye cat I'd like to give that kind of
lethal dose of something maybe I should
give that some CBD cuz that's what we're
talking about here folks I don't want to
blow I don't want to ruin the surprise
but it's true many people in my
generation we just fed pharmaceutical
drugs by they're lazy and inadequate
parents okay and they end up they end up
like fighting anxiety with drugs that
cause all kinds of problems that's where
nobody's dick works anymore because
they've all been on [ __ ] anti-anxiety
meds forever so the move here folks is
CBD what is it CBD is the hemp plant and
unlike its sister Mary Jane that means
marijuana CBD contains less than 3% THC
okay so it's not the psychoactive drug
THC which is what gets you high this is
not about getting high I'm sober up and
sober for eight years
I endorsed this product I think it's
great several double-blind studies have
shown that CBD reduces anxiety it's
absolutely true I know people that give
Brenda Schwab give CBD to his son it
helps him with his epilepsy okay also
been slow to have been shown to
alleviate depression as well as pain and
inflammation and help with sleep and a
lot of people are having sleepless
nights because all day they they think
about their life and then they go lay in
bed and they go god what did i do today
I blew it all didn't I yes but you
should still be able to sleep
unlike many CBD products on Amazon or
online shopping sites uncommon
apothecary products are third-party
tested to ensure quality and consistency
I like that I like that they don't trust
their own people I appreciate that
third-party tested uncommon apothecary
okay
posted right to the site they're not
trying to hide anything
of all it is legal without prescription
in all 50 states
we have pet formulas so your best friend
and you can take it together so if you
have a dog like my friend has Australian
Shepherd it's a piece of [ __ ] and it
attacks everybody and I have this fat
cat that escapes all the time it's not
even my cat but I have to take care of
it because I moved into a divorce
doesn't matter neither here nor there
but what I'm saying is the reality is
you could take it with your patent I
know I say the reality is too much and
it's annoying the reviews speak for
themselves Jerry from Michigan says I
purchased from my grandparents both of
which are in their late 60s they've used
it daily for just over a week now and
they love it it helps to ease their pain
caused from arthritis at knee
replacements allowing them to be more
functional during the day and sleep
easier at night great product be funny
if it was like Jerry for Michigan says I
purchased for my grandparents both of
which are in their late 60s they had
been withdrawing in the latter latter
years of their life they've been getting
strange ending phone calls very very
quickly and not sending out any birthday
or Christmas cards we worried about them
during the holidays it was a real
darkness in their eyes it looked like
something was going wrong once I went by
their house and they didn't know I was
there and I saw them standing in the
backyard wearing robes they were holding
hands and chanting and they were burying
something in a little box I don't know
what it is then I started to pull
newspaper clippings of kids that had
gone missing in their area 30 kids had
gone missing in the last 25 years it's
very interesting I started to put
together that many of those kids went
missing in a three mile radius of where
they lived I started looking at some of
the art in their house it was very
strange Devil's and satanic symbols I
didn't realize it before well I pretty
much figured out that they were
murdering children maybe abusing them
sexually I don't know but
they were a big problem so we don't
bring the kids over there anymore but
they do make a pretty decent grilled
cheese and I did get them the CBD and
they are sleeping easier now so let's
let bygones be bygones so folks head
over to UA CBD calm today UA
slash CBD calm UA - CBD calm and use the
code Dillon 15a check out to receive 50%
off Dillon 15a check out ok for every
item purchase uncommon apothecary will
donate one to local homeless shelters
which I am against that but I they will
do it that is a joke I'm all for that
you a - CBD comm use the code Dillon 15
for 15% of check out
listen CBD is good it helps it fights
anxiety it fights inflammation literally
it is like a miracle drug everyone talks
about it rogue and everybody that you
respect talked about this drug if you're
a fan of my show and you like the show
and you're going to buy CBD this is a
great way to do it okay you a - CBD calm
use the promo code Dillon 15 you'll get
15% off after checkout they have all
kinds of CBD products literally
everything
go to the site play around with it again
it's a great way to support the show if
you are a consumer of CBD and if not
it's definitely something to try thank
you I am I was like always bad with
money man I was never good with money I
didn't come from a family that was good
with money
I didn't understand money I still barely
understand money
um I'm not the worst with money but I'm
not good I spend too much I'm too
generous Irish people are stupidly
generous let me just you're very like my
dad I go out to dinner with people that
have so much more money than him and
just pick up the check do you feel like
working in sales also gave you that
habit as well yeah yeah
I'm starting to get that now job sales
guys want to show everybody that they're
the guy mm-hmm so a lot of it's like
throwing down the card I got it and your
sales is all about trying to convince
the world you're doing better than you
are
hmm so people want to [ __ ] get on
board with what you're doing you know so
part of that is like that fake it till
you make it yeah I throat a card I got
it and then you start realizing you
start buying dinners for people that not
just have a little more money than you
but could buy and sell you like you're
being ridiculous yeah like it's absurd
there's a lot of money out there and I
wish people are just not good with money
there's something about Irish people I
think is it drinking maybe the
depression yeah part of its the drinking
I think also part of it is that it's not
like it's not a culture that prizes
education
neither did Italian yeah Jews did mm-hmm
Asians and Indians did yeah oh yeah
Irish were all about like let's get
government jobs
let's hit people with stacks yeah its
own bars its own restaurants Italians
were the same thing at times distrusted
institutions outside of family and the
church so they like education things
like that it wasn't like you know so you
know but Irish people there's something
about the party atmosphere hmm everybody
having fun everybody drinking money on
the bar and you know none of that lends
itself to like you know prudent
financial decisions yeah nobody inherits
money goes what is Malachy if the bar
think what is thrown in and think I
should do just Terry have any ideas of
what I should do with this well yes
we'll run it into the ground together
well run it into the ground together
like this is how dumb some Irish people
are mm-hmm I was on my tour bus and
there was I was when I was a tour guide
in New York City on those double-decker
buses we're outside it was a beautiful
day and there was a bunch of guys it
walked out a Barclays which is a big
bank in New York City
and they were like yeah such young men
here they all have jobs you're all doing
well and I'm like those guys probably
make two or three hundred thousand
dollars a year yeah they're loaded this
is that dumb these Irish people are they
go but they're cooped up inside all day
you got the Sun and I'm like well that's
why we have nothing yeah that's why we
have nothing but they're cooped up
inside you got the Sun you're at a
check-cashing Bella Noma they're cooped
up inside all that they can't go out and
walk in the tall grass
I sleep outside why even be alive
yeah disgusting but great if you you
know great writers great storytellers
you guys are from Texas what is your
background what is your ethnic
background um we're just white trash
it's nothing really we didn't get any
education on your so would you say that
you guys are European are you like me
we're Dutch we're like 1/32 Native
American word yeah Russian English Irish
and then out 0.6% Ashkenazi Jew so
really yeah mm-hmm okay I would like you
guys to put the mics down years ago
yeah but sneak up on you right you
tinkin what's your background
English Irish German is there anything
that sticks out cuz see for being from
Long Island New York is Irish Italian
Jewish and those are very distinct
cultures so like everybody that I know
one of those cultures played like a role
in their life or you know I black
friends it is bad affair yeah those are
very distinct cultures too right so I
mean there was nothing we were like
we're like fourth generation so it was
just completely bread a roast beef on
Christmas and that was about the only
tradition that we have okay yeah but
that was my me and my grandfather what
kind of recipes like a nice roast beef
you carve it like deli roast beef that
y'all just no no no
my grandpa would would roast it on the
spit out yeah that's right it'd be grass
right lots of coolers lights around lots
of quart cans lots of was a good man
grandpa was a good man lots of lectures
about how to appropriately use the pool
table we had to put my grandfather a
pool table - it was like generation love
billiards absolutely they loved you
don't [ __ ]
don't touch the pool table right tell
grandpa has showed you how to use a pool
cue I've told you this yeah I think my I
think one of my dad's brothers I
scratched the felt on the pool table my
grandfather like beat him within an inch
of his life percent yeah he deserved it
me and Ben we visited our rich Jersey
relatives and was it Ellen broke the
chandelier I broke it Dan broke the
shinny over the pool table we were
terrified they'd just throw us in jail
we're doing the yank up then one of the
Yankee cue ball and rip it into the it
was probably like 10 grand yeah it's an
amateur mistake yeah my grandpa wouldn't
stand for that [ __ ] I wouldn't even I
have to change my last name if I had
that well that was from that generation
man where a lot of those guys had
literally nothing like we talked about
how we're all [ __ ] and we're not gonna
retire and have houses and [ __ ] that's
well true you know but those guys like
my grandfather started out with very
little he was very poor yes Chelsea
Handler he was wide at it we know is why
I understand that he had it easier than
black people Thank You Chelsea Handler
for telling me that from the backyard of
your bel-air mansion while you interview
another white guy who wrote a book about
white privilege mm-hmm is there anything
this deserve anything will tell you more
why Trump will win than that scene yeah
where she a white chick who's a multi
millionaire interviews another white guy
who wrote a book about white privilege
in the in the backyard of her bel-air
mansion
it's a [ __ ] SIOP it's so bad it's so
bad like that it was high they had hired
by extra-hard to the dock and we're
talking about the documentary hello
privilege it's me Chelsea
mm-hmm there are parts of the dock that
are like [ __ ] haunting because you
know tons of horrible [ __ ] went down
anybody who says why people haven't had
it substantively easier than black
people just
of history you don't know anything you
know no doesn't mean all white people
but the way that the middle class was
created was completely unavailable to
black people all kinds of loans federal
grants all that [ __ ] owning property all
of that is 100% true so there's things
in the documentary that are like god I
just wanted to hear that civil rights
lady talk more yeah she was interesting
that one was a hero so of course she was
on for about three minutes and then the
rest of it is Chelsea Handler talking to
her old boyfriend you know she hasn't
seen in 25 years
some black that she was banging at 15
and I boarded his kid and then he goes
to jail for a bunch of drug-related
offenses and she dips and closer makes a
couple million bucks a lot of more than
a couple yeah and then comes back 25
years later with a Netflix crew yeah she
comes back with a production crew see
her first time she's seen a guy yeah
first time she's seen the guy and she
comes back with a film crew that's
insane
yeah well Tim she greeted I don't know
if you caught that she greeted him and
she's like you've been out of jail what
14 years now he's like no I was in jail
for 14 years I've been out for two
she's like sorry the sound was muffled
did you say that again
would you mind saying that again and by
the way your camera's camera too
did you say to camera two she's like I'm
so excited to see your mother she walked
into the house she's like hi grandma she
gives the old woman hog the old lady's
leg the grandma hey grandma
it's me Chelsea how you doing girl girl
you want to floss real quick there's
nothing more disgusting sweater yeah
here you go
she's worth she was interesting about it
she didn't show up with anything like I
guess it would have been inappropriate
to bring gifts
probably I wonder you're better than
just nothing listen I don't know her I
know people that know her I don't know
her at all I wonder if she writes them a
check
I would hope figure hopefully right but
she also seems like such a [ __ ] yeah
but maybe that's I don't know I saw her
on a plane watch like elbowed me no
she's in first class
what she knew you know like I don't know
if she was like settling in or see she
was just kind of like get away from the
fat white mass you fat white blob yeah
she spends most of documentary talking
to this dude in her backyard mm-hmm and
she's like you know she supposedly paid
for all her like brothers and sisters
care I knew her brother Roy handler a
real chef who was friends with one of my
fat friends Tracey karna I was a
comedian in New York shoutout to Tracey
she know she's fat
she used to do this diet called whole
thirty we were to house one day and
Tracey goes I'm doing whole 30 and Ray
turn around 128 30 whole chickens
weirdest a cast once first time I had
like caroline's maybe 2015 we would do
quality meat steak house in New York and
Ray gets enraged with fat people like
pretend to be on diets you know it's
kind of hilarious show Tracey they they
put an appetizer down on the table and
it's bacon with like miso peanut butter
and jalapeno apple jelly it's so amazing
and instead of just not eating it or
abstaining she looked at the way there
she goes I don't really eat bacon a
register of I shot the [ __ ] mad but
Tracy was friends with this guy Roy
handler like Chelsea excommunicated Roy
and for whatever reason like he lived
with Chelsea for a while then they got
in a fight and then like she wouldn't
speak to him anymore he was with her in
LA I think they lived together yeah in
LA he live with her for a while then
they got in some argument they don't
speak right she really she was white
yeah should be like
white boy you're a white really use the
deal did she started realizing that when
it became hip of course when it became
the thing to do
she's a known climber yeah and a lot of
the people who turned on a dime like
that's why I respect the [ __ ] out of
Janeane Garofalo
Janine's been doing political [ __ ]
forever cheney was in like during the
Iraq war when Chelsea was talking about
it puss Jeanine was talking about Cheney
and Halliburton Cheney has been going up
trying to get people to wake up about
[ __ ] for a [ __ ] long you know and
Jeanine gets booed she gets [ __ ]
hostile reactions and she's not full of
[ __ ] did and she defended Louie and got
[ __ ] for it
like that's the thing she doesn't like
his mob mentality culture because
Janeane Garofalo is an actual person
that gives a [ __ ] and she's actually
used her art to try to get people to pay
attention to [ __ ] and all of these
people now they're jumping on that
bandwagon are complete frauds and she
knows it she's like we're the [ __ ] rule
of you and we're locking people up at
Guantanamo Bay
oh they be Nazis you got them a Netflix
special yeah they don't give a [ __ ]
about your Mullen said that Montague's
some of these well people would be Nazis
100% they love the iconography of just
being part of this movement that they'd
never questioned yep they just love
putting it out there
gasps Quaid get him on the train Nazis
are just another that's Yas Queen he's
just another Heil Hitler you can't do
anything if you're not a New York time
makes everything start to build yeah
people out here for whatever reason you
release East Coast time just that's what
Netflix releases [ __ ] west coast I'm
like why what are you doing I don't know
I just feel like New York for whatever
reason maybe there's more hustle bustle
I feel like [ __ ] you start my fanbase is
more New York too but I think they just
start [ __ ] starts to catch fire quicker
they catch it first and then it goes
viral by the time the West Coast right
yeah these [ __ ] out here are
sleeping or thrown away two hours yeah
at least three hours well if you know
the correct time stuff yeah exactly
allow privilege it's me Chou Singh high
privilege we're gonna pass I'm
privileged hi i'm privileged chelsea
quite frankly we're good
hello precious that's me Chelsea
Gabourey Sidibe hi privilege this is
Chelsea hey Chelsea its privilege we've
met before we've known each other for a
while and frankly I don't like that
you're not talking [ __ ] about me when
I've had your back literally forever
literally forever mm-hmm I love the
beginning of it sets out where you see
her house and you know these jokes and
I've had it hard I'm jealous because she
wants to show that she has like some
self-awareness I'm like and it starts
with her maid cleaning her house yeah
yeah her maids cleaners and then she's
like I wrote a book club you've got to
be kidding me so I wasn't thinking about
myself I was thinking about a funny
you're still thinking about yourself and
solving the world's problems your
Netflix all of that people call her out
through the whole thing like yeah this
isn't gonna be solved with like a
Netflix special you [ __ ] like no like
multiple people like yeah this isn't
what you think it is mm-hmm
Chelsea's like well how can what are we
supposed to do with white people it's a
donate money donate your time how about
get to tell the cameras to go home and
go make a poor person a sandwich yeah so
something go hire an attorney for
something like you know donate the ACLU
anything she wants in it these people
want em years they want to be recognized
they want a legacy because she's
probably like I've talked about my [ __ ]
for a decade mm-hmm talked about my
curse lapis which was just to call her
[ __ ] I talk about my kiss lapis for a
decade and I [ __ ] you know she [ __ ]
you know she's got nothing with John
rivers Jenna rivers called her out Joan
Rivers like you're fine you [ __ ] a
head of a yeah you know he was like you
come at me [ __ ]
yeah I'm the first person you had a late
night show the first woman who had a
late night return do you think she
[ __ ] up by going in the race angle
instead of the rape angle I feel like
that would have been better for her like
diving into the me to stuff I don't know
man I know people that
our and it's just like there's an
intensity tour you can see in her eyes
there's an intensity to her she's
clearly successful she's coolly driven
you know she she [ __ ] she's got a
hustle right and she's got a hustle so
somebody with a hustle man it's very
interesting I'm sure she is guilty and
I'm sure she does in her own head think
what she's doing is good I I think
that's the thing I like it's only sin
it's cynical but it's also like she
believes that this is good yeah nobody
thinks they're a bad person
that's how evil happens this people
themselves a good narrative here's what
she did she goes to Oktoberfest and gets
these white people that are buffoons and
they'll go we don't know about why
privilege why he made
she gives people are getting hammered at
Oktoberfest to basically go and then she
gets four Republican lawmakers were not
even lawmakers women in like the local
Republic Club of Orange County in him
like brain-dead Chardonnay swilling
morons real housewife
yeah real housewife types who were just
wasting the Real Housewives at least
have like job these [ __ ] are like
what do they even do it like going going
to fundraisers while their husbands [ __ ]
some 22 year old on a golf course who
knows like she's talking to them like
that's the people you're trying to get
right women just posting on next door
and that's who she's she doesn't she so
she easily like just finds these morons
and I'm not saying that there's not a
lot of those people out there but what's
the victory there okay
what's the victory again you got a bunch
of morons to sit in your backyard and I
said dumb things good for you yeah well
you know it's just a it's a it's a love
story to the [ __ ] to Hollywood and
[ __ ] it's the same stuff because that
kind of stuff isn't gonna it's just
gonna infuriate the people that it's
targeted targeting what people don't
realize white privilege is absolutely
real but the bigger problems that we are
a country full of deeply selfish
Psychopaths really mm-hmm and it's like
is it raises here yeah but there's a
lotta a lot of problems yeah there's a
lot of demons running amok yeah I did a
show in Jersey and I was talking about
GoFundMe have a bit about GoFundMe in
perfect American attitude I'm like you
ever donate to GoFundMe and a woman in
the front row fat Jersey beast goes
who's funding us you know the perfect
American answer I didn't think about
Billie Eilish I'm like isn't this weird
she's bleeding out of her eyes
something's wrong there right dressing
up like Satan in the videos and then
somebody in the back of she makes a lot
of money Oh God
here's the same HECO when you're talking
about Epstein I mean this is a country
where people brought their kids to
Michael Jackson's bedroom so they could
get [ __ ] cuz he had a nice house you get
a free trip to boys this is America this
is what these are the people that live
here you know
if it was only racism there was a
problem God would that be a breath of
fresh air if it was strictly race that
these people were weird about and not
and I'm not saying that's not a huge
[ __ ] problem but I mean we're living
with with people that are just
completely [ __ ] unhinged corporations
are like buying all the water for the
next 20 years yeah dude I'm telling you
I say it as a joke but I'm telling you
right now there will be an American
Ninja Warrior type show where people
will compete for insulin and the people
competing will say it's a privilege to
be here I'm lucky to be I'm lucky to be
here I love all those competition shows
people go on they're like I'm lucky to
be here
I'm so lucky to be here and get out
there and be judged by Chrissy Teigen
and some other people that are
collecting a check to sit in judgment of
my passion yeah and tell me whether or
not I should what I should do with my
life you know
that's why I respect the the boomers
that raised all of us the drunks uh you
know I wish there was more alcohol in my
house my mom would do at Bartles &
Jaymes and then we'd watch Romancing the
Stone and she thought she'd complain
about dad not loving her enough yeah and
I'd be like mom it's okay it's all right
hit me yeah let's get it oh boy yeah
happy lives yeah yeah not everything's
at night every time one of us opens our
mouth that's a goddamn night and mother
would sit on the couch and sip of tea
and cry softly and I would braid her
hair and put makeup on and tell her that
no one could see the bruises I mean
Williams football season is upon us
folks Jeffrey Epstein is out of the news
we're moving on
you like winning money of course you do
you like betting sports of course you do
what else are you gonna do with your
life I'll tell you where I put my money
down my bookie dot AG you can bet on the
NFL baseball MMA whatever my bookies got
it they've got better incentives and
more lines and any other supports put
period okay they got everything they
have these uh all kinds of like
non-traditional bats dude
that are pretty cool a prop that you can
bet on something unconventional you get
bet on like Trump resigning which will
never happen but you can bet 100 bucks
and you'll win 1,200 you know there's 12
to 1 odds like these are fun bets we'll
come up with a few of those bats you
know we could do like you know you could
bet that just Lane Maxwell would be
arrested which obviously she's not gonna
be but you can do bets like that it
doesn't have to be sports but listen
they're great at sports and I'm telling
you this right now folks my pic right
now okay I'm gonna say Monday Night
Football Chicago and Washington I say
the Bears minus four and uh under
Redskins team total 19 I don't really
give it I don't know I know everything
about this
my friend Michael is picking these out
because he's like a degenerate gambler
and he like ran like
the service where people would bet with
him and he's like that kind of guy he's
like a slimy guy so he knows about this
so he's giving me my pics you know I
don't really give a [ __ ] about sports
I'll do some other fun bets
you know like society collapses when
here we go folks I'm gonna say it again
bears minus four and under Redskins team
total which is nineteen okay
bet that Redskins suck they have a
racist name and their owners a
billionaire [ __ ] okay my friend is
really good at these picks by the way
he's not bad at them you know I'm
telling you he's gonna be really helping
me out in this in this until I really
get until I get a little better at it
because he's from that world he's in
that world okay well it's important to
me that I give you guys the information
that you need so that you can go and bat
they just revamp their site my book if
you've been on my book II been yeah I've
used it I encourage shut up I encourage
you all of you to go and take a look if
you haven't already okay it's fun to bet
on things it is fun to gamble I remember
I went to a bachelor party with a friend
of mine we went to Atlantic City which
is really like a Disney World for
chain-smoking amputees and it's really
really bad my friend Mike Lawrence made
a great point because these people think
they're gonna be lucky they all have
like their missing limbs they're gonna
be lucky now it was interesting we went
to Show Boat casino which was like this
horrific kind of racist like you know
themed casino in Atlantic City that was
going out of business right next to
Trump's cuz you know which was also kind
of going out of business people are just
you know if doing heroin in the
bathrooms and you know there's rats
running around but the I mean I was
playing I think three-card poker we're
just having a good time it's fun to
gamble and it's much more fun to gamble
and not leave your house that's the move
here you can win money you got my
audience can do it you can do it you can
win why don't you win why don't you go
and be somebody
stop listen if your fiancee run her
mouth go and take life by the [ __ ]
balls make a little money and then you
tell her where you're going on vacation
Kang you know she's disgusted with you
cuz you don't have the kind of money
that her friends men do you know she's
got to talk about how funny you are at
brunch with those other birds it's
disgusting
we in a little bit get a little money
tell you right now that's the way to do
it and don't do it in a traditional way
who cares the working man is a sucker
don't be a sucker take all of the money
that you earn and bet okay double your
first deposit now if you use promo code
Tim you get 100% bonus on your initial
deposit up to $1,000 if you deposit 500
you get a thousand if you deposit a
thousand you get 2,000 don't be stupid
folks if you like to bet this is the
site to bet 100% and if you don't like
to bet you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and and
nobody respects you
you have a soft penis it never gets hard
and your wife stands there waiting and
then she goes into masturbates in the
bathroom because she cannot she can she
married this [ __ ] [ __ ] that is afraid
to go out there and take a chance you're
afraid to risk okay
I'm telling you the Bears are gonna win
Monday night I've looked at the spreads
and the statistics and I've I've done
the work I've done my due diligence
okay the Bears have a great team they
got uh that the big guy and then the few
other ones they're gonna [ __ ] win
what is the Redskins got what are they
got they got nothing they got a bunch of
Nazis running around that they're
they're they they they're their name is
the Washington Redskins that's that's a
real name you imagine that's a name
that's ridiculous what are you gonna
wear I mean what kind of what kind of
organization would
they should change their name to the
Washington intersectional feminist or
something that's respectful and and
positive like the Washington you know
Native American alliance I don't know
but it's what do you think about the
game you're ready for the game
the Bears I'm ready I'm ready I'm going
for it on the Bears the well everybody
loves the big guy he's already Saget bad
everybody says Ben's gay and I tried to
let him let him defend themselves by
having some sports knowledge and of
course he's got coming his throat you
can't saying he's like I'm betting on
the PGA Tour tomorrow
oh the PGA Tour that's good you bone
smoking quitter
[ __ ] can't watch football you know he
can only come off his chick [ __ ] him
okay say my twink seems gay you [ __ ]
alright folks I can say I could say the
word [ __ ] because I'm a black gay man
double your first deposit now folks
who's even thinking about this get in
there and start betting if you enjoy my
show if you have the balls to make
something if you want to win get in
there that's my bookie my B oh okay ie
and don't forget to use the promo code
Tim T I am when creating your account to
claim the bonus TI M is the way you
claim your bonus deposit 200 bucks you
get 400 you play around you have some
fun report in show me that you've won
show me that you've won we'll talk about
it on the show we'll talk about you on
the show well bring you out to LA you'll
be famous
I'm telling you win a few games at my
bookie I'll bring you out to LA I'll get
you a movie deal and then make a movie
about your interesting life okay I'm so
excited
for this game on Monday you know I look
like a guy that really wants to always
talk about people come up to me and talk
about football me all the time I just
stare at them I don't really watch
football but I have that I look like a
guy that would care a lot about football
so when people come up to me they're
like they say stuff and I'm just like
yeah yeah Wow you know it's what it is
now it's a different game sometimes if
I'm in a football conversation and I
don't know what to say
I saved myself by go hey [ __ ] Colin
Kaepernick so people understand that
even the football is important it's more
important to be racist you know what I
mean
so that's a great way to get yourself
out of football conversation is to just
steer it into racist waters that's my
bookie and I'm not a racist I'm just
saying sometimes in order and I think
Colin Kaepernick is great I think he's
fine but in order to get out of a
technical conversation about sports I
have to I have to you know Stewart
towards that my bookie my B ook ie
Michael Michael is making the bets here
so if you don't win you will win because
Michael is a legit dirtbag like he is a
legitimate dirtbag 100% like is a
garbage person [ __ ] he cares about
sports and a long time ago he was you
know like you know hookers and sports
and cool [ __ ] I respect that
everybody loves [ __ ] by the way but do
you not see every person you respect
loves horse okay
every [ __ ] fun little comedian or
actor you think you think they're like
wholesome let me tell you right now
they're whipping someone in a hotel room
my bookie my B oh okay i e.com Tim will
double your money get in there and win
teach your kids how to gamble
is about chance everything is gambling
the economy is gambling risk/reward do
you get that dum dum
take a risk stop going to college and to
get on loans and getting degrees you
failure you know that adds up to [ __ ]
the guys are really maybe the one to
take risks take chances I know a lot of
people that have gambled in one you can
always get back up dust yourself off and
win again that's where people that are
addicted to gambling they think they're
kind of addicted to losing because it's
like that great feeling of just being
like I'm bottom down but I can guys got
nowhere to go but up that's what I want
for you all of you I want you to feel
that feeling you have nowhere to go but
up you're gonna win tim is a promo code
if you enjoy my show and you want to
[ __ ] around if you're a man with a big
penis that you put wherever you want
with consent and everybody's happy about
it you've got that kind of penis if you
if you're a weird man a beta male and
you don't have a penis maybe even then
maybe don't you know but if you are a
man you better you and you're a woman
too if you're a woman or a man I mean
bloody the audience is men so I'm not
gonna be an idiot here and start you
know act like I have an audience of a
ton of women I don't
some of them listen I respect their
intelligent one let's be honest the
women listen to show a little
intelligent and a lot of them out there
are not let's be honest and I'm not
saying I'm not saying there's a lot of
men that aren't intelligent too but the
women that Alysha show they're on a
higher vibrational plane than the rest
of them that's it sorry same with the
gay people is in this show men anyone
who's listening this show you want a
higher vibrational plane than the rest
of society you're you are better than
they are and that's why you should
gamble okay because you got it they
don't got it you got it my B oh okay i
e.com Tim use promo code Tim if you like
my show and you want to take a chance
get in there and and make me proud
make your daddy proud make your wife and
kids
and win some goddamn money for Christ
Bob and Sue my friend Paul and these
parents Bob and Sue a shoe has always
got to be a crazy [ __ ] oh yeah
a sue you know not a good name I have an
aunt you they call it Charlie Christian
closes down the bars with the boys they
call it Charlie Osmond but Charlie I
love it she's great
Charlie one day they live in this place
and it's it's awesome Rockaway Beach
Queens has these little courtyards of
summer bungalows and a full of Irish
people and they just get bombed that
bars called Healy's in the Irish Circle
and one day not my family but the family
that lived across the little courtyard
from them the daughter came in and she
was bombed and you could tell she was
just wobbling
she was like 17 and every one the court
was laughing and the mother walks out
guys
yo she had some dumb Irish like Mary or
Flanagan are you drunk
she goes no and then she spins around
and Exorcist vomits and then she looks
right at her mother goes I'm not drunk
and you're cooking so the whole court
applauded started applauding her
applauding she sits down this girl can
barely move and somebody turns around I
swear to god it goes you want a glass of
wine I pity people they went to college
in a 401k plan I don't have these
stories yeah what would you do without
the stories yeah you know I know we grew
up Christian so we had to like jam them
all into like 22 to 25 yeah you guys you
guys basically went on rum spread which
is that Amish year with a black [ __ ]
Sun really good I did like mushrooms for
an entire month
what was the first time that you guys
either got drunk or
hi or whatever cuz you for people that
don't know you guys you guys were in a
super conservative Christian Church like
real deal
yeah Church of Christ it was like if I
describe it to people they're like yeah
that's a cult they - so we didn't do we
were gonna let us say but until we were
like 15
oh yeah conservative farmers can't say
fart can't say fart so the first time I
did anything bad I was 20 and I got
tricked into it did you guys start
jerking off or did you go like we're
gonna be we're gonna go to hell
I mean you're 12 so you're gonna jerk
off but you just like without guilty I
thought I was going to be tortured in
hell for all eternity so funny I used to
jerk off in like a bad comic joke I
literally used to cry afterwards cuz I
thought I was gonna go really if I was
gonna be raped by the devil and health
yeah ever you jack off and then you feel
bad and then you pray and you pray that
God will forgive you and it's it's sort
of this this rush it's a high you get
cuz it's like you think you're going to
hell while you're doing it because Aaron
Carney I would also cry afterwards
something wrong about you are going to
hell yeah you're sure that by the way I
hope so I hope I'm in hell with the
Murdochs guys can go to heaven loser him
I used to no joke I would lay in bed
because our dad told us the world be
destroyed in a wall of fire yeah one day
when Judgment Day came along like a
thief in the night yeah so I would lay
in bed just wait cuz I hadn't been
baptized yet so I knew I was going to
hell and I was jerking off so you should
just lay in bed waiting for the wall of
fire to come through the wall and just
take me to hell I don't they baptize you
gotta earn it you you gotta choose it's
kind of like Mitzvah oh yeah and you're
like 13 14 have to choose to be saved
boom yeah just get taken care of at
first my grandfather like baptized one
of the kids in the st. cuz like like the
mother was like we don't know if he's
gonna be religious he's going with us
new face yeah and we thought you in
there
Sephardic probably we don't know right
so what was the first time like was it
when you went to college did you guys
drink in high school I drank it was the
day after my high school graduation I
was 19 I think at the time and I was at
a house party on a ranch like 20 miles
away from
when I got tricked into it so it was
like hey try this Oh J and they put
Everclear and a bunch of sweet and low
in it so I wanted to taste them
Everclear and then I got drunk off that
I started just you know [ __ ] like
going crazy like taking my shirt off and
[ __ ] and you were like we did you feel
like God this is the [ __ ] I was a I'm
like I'm gonna do this every day for the
next seven years and I did yeah you're
just like this is I guess is how normal
people feel yeah but the thing is we
didn't learn how to have fun the way
like Tim had fun walking around Long
Island smoking weed getting high like
you learned how to have fun at early age
it prepared me for literally the the
only job I can ever have which is this
yeah like I mean it really yeah there's
no we used to like drink in a closet
because we were like ashamed and just
get drunk and then just like sit in the
living room and that was our fun and so
when you both went to a Christian
College mm-hmm and you were the first
time in no supervision that's when
that's when [ __ ] hit the fan yeah like
drinking and driving pretty much every
night we go to like Walmart's yeah
doughnuts on the highway we were like
insane but it was Texas everybody drunk
and drugged that was the most fun you
could have his drink and drive really I
mean it's let me tell you right now I am
a huge proponent of drinking there is
nothing that feels better than being
intoxicated behind the wheel of a car
mm-hmm what was your go-to song the
guy's dogs gotta calm down this [ __ ]
Aussie needs to be [ __ ] thanked CBD
oil cut it out she needs a CBD um sorry
they hate drinking and would go to that
you would you would turn on when you
drink and drive I like to be 6 mafia so
the album what was the first g-unit
album was it get rich or die trying'
that was 50 cent yeah I get rich or die
trying'
in the club yeah wangster all that and
yeah that was a big one diplomats sir
blueprint to jay-z godson nas you know
good [ __ ] I'm last real alive
Jadakiss the lock Styles P I got I got a
little Billy Joel Oh Charisse Hendrix
job I mean we
it was eclectic we're all over I was all
over the place and then you know some
emo [ __ ] some blink-182
some starting line right now just
blacked out what was that oh we are I
usually go out this girl who loved that
song crazy game of poker was it is this
crazy game of poker what else was good
or not good but what else are we
listening to the general that's what
this match I have seen the other we have
oh yeah yeah I mean Nirvana sure all
that [ __ ] I mean whatever I'm just
naming [ __ ] that I just remembers like
popping into my head I'll Jam ever yeah
Pearl Jam that Foxy Brown song whoa yo
yo biggie PAH like all that Shing Run
DMC Cameron Cameron love that [ __ ]
whatever man but there's no better
feeling there's a few great feelings
there's no better feeling and pulling in
your driveway racked beautiful chosen
this when you pull in your driveway and
you are ready and you just pull in you
take the keys out of the ignition get
out of the car you like the ciggy and
you're like I'm home and I'm a smart guy
you feel like accomplished yeah feel
like you just got into college that's a
white trash getting into college that's
an acceptance letter like I'm smart and
responsible you actually internalize it
as you did the right thing I did the
right thing I know where my car cuz dude
I used to get so [ __ ] up I wake up I
go to this bar on my town and I'm like
where's my car like we don't even know
and I'm like what happened they're like
you went to another bar you were doing
coke I was like a big lunatic Republican
you doing coke and yelling about how the
Iraq Wars the best thing and that we
need to honor our commits they were like
you were just screaming at oh but we
need to honor our commitments wire to
the cup people of Iraq so [ __ ] I'm like
yeah I'm like like what's my car like no
idea where your car is
and we'd have to like detective work
like drive around my my friend Brian
half would come pick me up
we don't look do [ __ ] though hey when I
bought my house Brian was in the car or
driving 2007 2006 2007 we're driving to
the closing I had never even seen the
house I'm buying a house I've never seen
not even pictures online pictures online
that is it yeah call it this total scam
buying this house I've never seen I'm in
the car my friend Brian half you go he
goes we'll we going I said Brian was
like a legendary kid he like fell all
the time walk it's just he would sit in
a chair like shake he drank so much
she's like dying he was a little guy and
he just drank so much just my friend's
dad took him out on a boat he like fell
off the boat he's do it he was wild and
he was mean him got in so much trouble I
remember one time did one time we were
and I'll get back this other story is
maybe one of my favorites well let me
tell housing first we're in the car and
I said buying a house and instead of
going how are you doing that how does
this work what's wrong with you he went
you're doing good
that one one of my favorite things ever
yet a brother as a special needs mmm we
were just smoking weed all day oh dang
and he pulls up to his house he goes I
just got a run and he goes I do got a
run and he goes no but he's gonna be
home I got a run in get my check you get
his check from work - it will get more
weed we pull up to his house there's
like 10 cars outside it goes like this
he goes oh [ __ ] he looks at his phone
he's got 48 missed calls
he goes I said what's going on he goes
it's my brother's birthday we gotta go
in I'm like we gotta go in dude we gotta
go in this house like I'm not a member
of your family like don't abandon me now
cuz we gotta go in that I'm like where
we gonna say we've been in for the last
48 hours he goes like this he goes I
don't know
literally he's like swaying he's so high
he walked into the house his mother
opens the door huh looks at both of us
just shakes her head and goes like that
she goes she looks at both of us and she
goes you're a disgrace
[Laughter]
we walked in his brother's like smiley
his brother got a nose we like we're
sing hello to the family like we the
family stares like the friends are there
neighbors are there it's totally
embarrassing so we walk back and his
father comes out back he goes
you think you two guys never get tired
of behind total Franco's
he was a guy I bought my house we just
used to get high in the house I bought
and watch Reno 911 EES we'd watch
seasons of Reno 911 we loved it we'd
watch it over and over again just so
[ __ ] high it sounds amazing dude in in
a house that was like decorated like
1970s and like thick carpets and weird
wallpaper I just bought it the market it
would just crash I was trying to get
tenants in it I was like 22 years old we
had this fat raccoon this thing was a
beast and it lived in a tree and it
would like paw at the door in the house
like it would paw at the door unafraid
like Let Me In and we just sat then
you'd see its shadow it was just walking
around it was just Oscar and Brian yeah
it looked like Oscar the cat and Brian
would look out back he's like that's a
big piece of [ __ ] dude he was I mean he
was just a wild dude he's one of those
dudes it was a wild guy we had a lot of
dude we had a lot of [ __ ] fun you
gotta get that out of your system
honestly well it was a decade you know
and that you had to yeah some you wonder
some people don't to have to go through
that yeah and then they just kind of
collapse into this lake what do you call
it been a non-player character NPCA yeah
just like the most boring person it with
like they watch The Bachelor and they
like fantasy football and then you know
they kill people do it at 40 some people
just had 40 when like they've raised
their kids their kids are in their teens
and they start to flip out yeah look at
Johnny Buffett type yeah some people
have that midlife crisis dude gets a
sports car he's like folks last week me
and the great red come had the privilege
of calling better help an online
counseling service and we filled out
their easy
questionnaire it only took us about 35
minutes and it was nice and they asked
they asked asked what your sexuality was
if you would rather go to pride
counseling which isn't one of their
offshoots the thing is folks there are
people out there that are in they're not
in the best predicament they feel sad
they feel anxious they feel bad and that
is legit we we have a huge mental health
crisis in this country that goes
unaddressed and then the people on
Twitter that supposedly care about
mental health when they have you know
when they had the chance to try to rip
Shane Gillis his life apart they really
pop on that what about that guy what
about his mental health I don't really
care about that huh interesting what
about the Covington kids mental health
how about all the death threats they
sent to them is that healthy I don't
think so
it's still funny it's around any time in
Los Angeles nothing would really make me
happier than to watch everyone in this
place burn the thing about better help
is that it's you know sometimes you need
help and you go on the internet and
sometimes you end up in a cult or you
end up marching with a tiki torch will
you end up thinking that you are a a
fairy woodland creature and that you're
a gender from outer space I don't know
but those aren't really the you don't
want those results you want to go to
better help they have good counselors to
I don't know that for a fact but what I
do they have people someone there will
answer the phone when they will talk to
you what do you think therapist is good
because they have a degree on their wall
hey hey
you can change your counsellor at any
time folks anytime if you do not like
your kept this cata so filthy if you do
not like your counselor you can change
your counsellor better help is a
resource for people that are a few days
out of going to youth hostel and they
need somebody to talk to you right now
before they do something cray cray okay
they could do something really Craig
Craig like like going to an open mic
before you go to an open mic start doing
comedy call better help because even
though their counselors may suck that
better than you deserve you know what I
mean they're better than what you
deserve I've never used the service
myself better help I tried it with
Raymond last week was very difficult
they haven't emailed me like 17 times
like are you okay are you still alive
what's your credit card number ray if
you haven't heard the last episode you
gotta listen to it when ranee and right
call better help and Ray does is one of
their questions there it goes
what's that ass like like that was one
of the questions on the brush war flag
[Laughter]
that called the better help claw from
last week is one of the funniest things
you know people have said to me you
shouldn't average house a better help
because they had this huge they were
huge YouTube sponsor and then they what
were they better I shouldn't take the
rants because it was a big scandal in
YouTube you know cuz they found out that
all the people had better help we're not
so listen if you have a fetish this is
how I've made okay with it in my head
sometimes you just want to hear somebody
on the other end of the phone while you
touch yourself I mean that's what it is
now you can't do that
somebody who you have to see or somebody
that you don't want to victimize
somebody by doing that without them
knowing but if their accounts there
better help who gives a [ __ ] this is a
place where you can go and masturbate
while somebody's on the other end of the
phone and it's okay like it's everyone
in society would be ok with that
you know or you could talk to them about
your problems I don't care what you do
doesn't matter to me what's the better
help what do we have to tell them
better hope calm better help calm / Tim
/ Tim Dylan Dylan Tim Dylan you get 10%
off your first month call them up go I
got a gun in my mouth and Ted Dylan sent
me please make sure you remember the
promo code even though it's a suicide
helpline please don't forget to let them
know that Tim Dylan sent you isn't that
great
we know you're at the lowest point in
your life but please use my promo code
tell them Tim sent you hey I feel like
everything's really bad and I just don't
know I don't want to fight through it
anymore I just want to end it and I want
to let you know the Tim Dylan sent me
you know go okay just make sure please
that you've used the promo code I know
that you're probably very upset but just
please focus and use the [ __ ] promo
code the right way don't start any
problems with me better help slash him
you can talk to them or you can touch
yourself better doesn't matter does it
matter which one you decide or maybe you
can you can stroke yourself while they
give you advice it doesn't matter
better have better help don't join a
gang go to better help well unless you
need to join a gang many of you probably
should it's great you know it's a great
way to teaches you a lot about family
not being a rat you know I don't like
that Takashi six nine going ratting on
everybody I've never been a fan of that
not a fan of that sir
pass pass on that better have better huh
who's gonna answer the phone that's part
of the fun
who the hell knows person answering the
phone might be more [ __ ] than you
better help such a funny title better
help like better than what's better than
nothing it's almost it almost should
call it's up better than nothing out you
know better help you know alright folks
but I mean what was your for cuz you
were a golfer when did you start boozing
Ben I didn't start drinking till I left
the church and this is what I'm saying
like I didn't know how to have fun the
first time I drank I watched that movie
Paul do you remember that that piece of
[ __ ] was Simon Pegg and he with the
alien I drank 12 shots watching that
movie with my friend
Smirnoff apple vodka Jesus that's what
first time I ever drank anything I drank
12 shots night threw up and that was
that was it and it was like I was like
oh I woke up I was like that was awesome
I was like that was the best time I've
ever had in my entire life rod that's
what I did every night for like it like
70 like this was amazing I think the
first time I remember drinking I think I
was in 11th grade and I went with my
friend Ryan wass legarre who's now
married and as a kid and as a good dude
we went to the Roosevelt Field mall okay
and we had dinner at this place called
the California whatever it was it was
like some [ __ ] long island's idea
like I'm scale restaurant and it was
like you know just like it was a
California style grilled pizzas and
salads and whatever and
they're specials like apple martinis so
we just started drinking these like
sewage colored how to Martinez mmm just
like act like like ecto cooler color
like that green and we just got kind of
drunk and I remember his dad came and
picked us up but we like played it off
we like now by the way I've done every
other drug before that really I had done
LSD I'd done cocaine I'd smoke weed I'd
taken pills all before that but from 13
14 15 I've done all that [ __ ] but the
the first time I drank wasn't gonna
laugh and gray mm-hmm and then I started
falling in love with booze yeah love
booze it's great but no good there was
nothing better than weed the first
couple years that you got to smoke it
it's better than booze but then the weed
stops working
the paranoia cons well here's what
happens right so there's there's there's
certain types of fun and for me the font
like the most I love laughing mm-hmm and
I love making people laugh right so the
funnest times I think I ever had
we're being stoned as a teenager with my
friends and just laughing yeah at
[Applause]
ridiculous [ __ ] I was on a stone yeah
yeah we used to we did this game where
we would go make up a slogan for a thing
so like when we was really stoned and
[Applause]
like this was later on we were we were
in or maybe early 20s and they would
give you a thing enough to make a slug
and then cold stone I remember one day
like what's a jingle we'd have to be
jingle I just want I was really I was
really [ __ ] up
we're all Community College and it had
no money and no jobs and still don't
like that dump like the dump but walking
around a mall food court and just you
know getting free samples eating a ranch
one chicken sandwich laughing and being
like none of this matters we can still
save our lives
yeah and the drinking in high school is
a lot of fun a lot of fun drinking in
high school and then right after high
school then you know I was in college
and then it starts to become a little
less fun because you're at a community
college and all your other friends are
going away to college and you're smoking
weed with a guy named Bunz you people
update me on bugs like I know my mother
gave puns his nickname no buns that well
he just had great wheat it was maybe the
best weed I've still ever saw and we
would smoke it on the top level of the
parking garage at at the mall loser [ __ ]
real losers like not even fun loser
so like when that era so I was like and
then I got into mortgages and I
discovered booze and coke which I never
really did at the same time I was always
just like either cocaine like I was
weird I just like to blow I have I never
really mixed a ton of drugs I was kind
of a [ __ ] like I don't want to OD or
whatever so I never mixed a lot that's
probably the only reason I'm alive I
never did like pills and blow and if I
was doing that I would do like no booze
will kill you the first time yeah so
like I didn't do any of that but that
level of fun was like I had a car so
then that's a whole different thing
right you have a car and if they're
worried that your car like I own a car
or I have a car if they're worried about
that but when you're 15 and you're just
walking around your town shrooming out
yeah
smoking weed shrooming out it was a my
friend's mother Barbara Magoo had a okay
I'm gonna say it slow okay but let me
tell you let me tell you why I have to
say
this is not this is not something that I
endorse but I have to say it because
this is what happened I don't wanna lie
to people I don't use this terminology
you're a storyteller there are two
people in our town that had a light
green Ford Taurus and one of them was my
friend's mother the other one was the
guy that delivered for the Chinese spy
so every time we would see this Ford
Taurus and we're like stone we didn't
want to talk to his mom so we would dive
behind the bush and then one of us would
just be like it's the [ __ ] it's the
chick we didn't hate the guy that's what
it is
he probably saw us because let's do
those two fat [ __ ] so that's why I had
to say this line right yeah I had to I
couldn't say the c-word while you called
him a con why are we calling him a con
that's reality but that dude
I remember between the ages of 13 and
probably like 15 those two years in my
life were spent walking around my town
stoned and terrified of bumping into
someone you knew like your parents she
would just be like looking out and whose
car is that is it my mother's white fan
is it your mom's green Taurus you know
well we went to we went to college me
and Ben in the town where we grew up so
we had to go to church still three times
a week so there was a lot of times I was
throwing up that morning there was one
story actually I threw up that morning
ironed my new slacks to go to church
because my family would be suspicious
ironed them for like 10 minutes I'm like
dizzy like you know all over the place I
finished ironing them and immediately
throw up on the
earning board is all for drunk driving
to church yeah driving to church I
couldn't take the communion cuz if I did
I would throw up
I had to palm taking the communion
Monday dot-com promo code Tim free
14-day trial Monday dot-com is a great
business resource many of you have small
companies that are failing and you don't
know why it is because you are not
organized it is because you were
thoughtless you are thick las' you have
no ideas you have no execution you're a
ball of anxiety you let your emotions
get the better of you you do not have
the formal or informal education you
lack the tenacity you do not work hard
you blame everything on your family and
friends you've not been able to meet
make any meaningful connections you are
not a good networker you're bad at
dinner parties you're bad everywhere you
don't have any love in your life no
support you're very lonely
you're a bad dresser you smell bad you
have no fashion sense you're bad in a
group you're bad alone you don't know
how to capitalize opportunities you
never even get opportunities most people
don't even notice you and you're in the
room you just kind of stand there the
ones that notice you were disgusted by
you but not even discussing the way that
they'd be interested in you they just
look at you and they're kind of like
what the [ __ ] and then they move on
you're forgettable ultimately
forgettable even your parents didn't
even really remember you they'd forget
you all the time like home alone except
not in a theatrical movie like way okay
and if you were Kevin McCallister during
home alone you never would have rigged a
bunch of cool booby Jeff you would have
just shat on your ass eat and cheese
that all week wouldn't ya cuz you're a
[ __ ] loser everything about you is
that you [ __ ] suck but that can all
change with Monday calm that's right
Oscar Monday calm okay his software that
helps create accountability well
you're two people collaborating or
multiple people across the globe Monday
comm allows you to streamline all of
your operations so that there's no
excuse to ever miss an email miss a
meeting miss an appointment
there's no excuse to not see an invoice
there's no excuse to not you know hit
that monthly target because you're gonna
know what that monthly target is you're
gonna know exactly what you need to do
to get there
there's no excuse to not call into the
conference call to not be productive to
not know exactly what the agenda of the
day week month year is Monday dot-com
will enable you to do all of that many
of you lack organization if I was
organized my life would be so much
better I'd be so much happier and
healthier you know but I'm not organized
I fly by the seat of my pants this
episode is gonna be late many of you are
gonna run your worthless mouths okay but
what you got to do folks is you got to
realize that Monday comm will help you
because you need help
that's a reality I've seen you I know
who you are you're the guy the things
you're gonna do it yourself and you're
not you're not you barely coherent when
you speak because you're disorganized
your thoughts are chaotic people don't
respect you
very hard we go on a date people don't
people are uninterested you fail to make
them interesting and this is the reality
folks if you do not if you do not let me
tell you right now what's gonna happen
you might you might you might not like
this if you do not purchase Monday
dot-com let me tell you what's gonna
happen you're going to be killed and why
do I know
because it would just make sense and you
won't even be killed in a fun way it
won't be monumental it'll just be
something that happens okay and I don't
mean you know killed whether you're
physically killed or you're just killed
in business it doesn't matter either way
it's just as bad you've got to step up
to the plate you got to stop blaming
everything on everybody else you didn't
have the childhood you wanted who cares
or your parents didn't give you the
breakfast cereal that you wanted who
gives a [ __ ] you didn't have the right
kind of friends you didn't come from the
right neighborhood you didn't get into
the right school wah-wah-wah cry me a
[ __ ] River littles hands a
multi-millionaire can barely speak Billy
Eilish doesn't even sing she's filling
stadiums going talents you don't need
talent you more in fact talents the
problem but if you were striving to be
good at something that's a waste of
[ __ ] time don't be good be organized
be effective these are what the things
I'm talented that means nothing I'm
laying in the floor somebody else's
house with this fat cat he's a real mess
um monday was a promo cone Monday
dot-com slashed him free for teenage for
Monday comm slash Tim you get a free
14-day trial so you can be a big
businessman everyone's gonna respect you
you show up to the high school reunion
and you say I made good I'm a local boy
and I did good cuz a Monday that I'm
calm
and they said weren't you the badminton
coach you touched a girl inappropriately
and you were fired and you go and then
you go she's a lying [ __ ] now I have an
online in the store where I sell camping
and fishing equipment I'm a nature
consultant that's actually a real thing
I made it up myself and
they dot-com mandate or come Monday
TOCOM you look here you know man in you
guy who do a bit differently
it's [ __ ] Monday talk home Monday
talk home bro map code Tim hey you're
[ __ ] Geordie you're [ __ ] Scouts
people from Liverpool are called
Liverpudlians I like that I think that's
a fun it's a fun way to do it
alright go away what what do you think
diverted you from golf cuz you were
taught to be like a real golf guy right
yeah I mean I was Allstate in high
school and I played in college that the
problem is dude is freshman year of
college my family left and I didn't have
any friends and that's when I stopped
going to church and so I had a huge
falling-out with them you know cuz my
dad's very upset my mom's upset I didn't
have I was going to a Christian College
where everyone was Christian so I was
very isolated I was very lone your also
living in an empty house but I was
living in the empty house that I grew up
in because mom Katie at college yeah
that's where I met Jenny so my first
year I gained the will they call it the
freshman forty I gained about 50 pounds
I didn't lost interest in golf
I lost all confidence in myself I
thought I was an [ __ ] because I
didn't have any friends I ate alone
everyday and I just I just
there were like days where I would lay
my head on my pillow and I'd realized
that I hadn't opened my mouth that day I
ain't spoken to anybody I just didn't
have any friends so that good old days
is the first year of playing golf
god it's so funny I'd such a loud fight
I've never had that
I've never went to bed when everyday I
go to bed I'm like I've said at least
4,000 words today to strangers if I have
two people at bus stops you at a
Buddhist simple you just I was the only
guy like on a bus stop talking about a
great George W Bush was like coked out
of my head just on a bus stop in Long
Island being like yeah he's [ __ ]
liberals they're trying to take
everything from us some Spanish lady
like nodding with her two babies
you should poor Bush I'm like I remember
one day I was on a bus I turned around a
kid we're both taking a bus okay I turn
around to him it's 2004 2003 like during
the election Bush v Kerry and I look it
would take I'm taking a bus to Community
College I'm stoned I'm not even a
full-time student or like I've dropped
classes I just look at this guy in the
bus online it's not even bush I'm like
what Bush we get [ __ ] chaining all of
the Cheney is there anything about it
is there anything about the tables of
did being an idiot being an ignorant
[ __ ] oh it is nice early and here's the
thing they haven't involved like know
everyone's still doing that out there
mm-hmm it's Trump now they like we've
got dog now nobody gives a [ __ ] you know
it's a better wife dude it's a life
we're like it's a life where you don't
really you don't think too deeply about
that life out there is full of people
just [ __ ] up and then get back to
zero just getting back to even that's a
lot of my friends just like like I'd
bump into a guy I'm like hey Pete how
you doing haven't seen you in a while
Isaac got a TV set me back two years on
my plan my plan what plan accept me back
two years on my plan but that's okay
he's like now um she's not working for
my father
okay structual my father
good man that's awesome what about you
when's the first time you I I mean I was
going to church until I was thirty so
like I was really why I ended I was I
was in it they mean that let me play my
[ __ ] drums they let me I used to do
all these videos for a church that had
like nine campuses it's a huge Church so
I get to do these comedy videos and and
[ __ ] like that but I didn't start
smoking I didn't do anything when I
started doing stand-up at 30 is when I
stopped going to church and then I found
weed at like 32 smoke that for the first
time at like 32 33 threw up because I
had like one drink and it threw me off
yeah we're just in a garage in Clovis
California you know watching I think
we're watching what the [ __ ] it dear
dick what's up Rob Rob Dyrdek show I a
hundred percent did County Mike when's
the first time you smoked weed Kevin I
was 46 46 years the late 40s late for
golden years you know no I waited for a
long time and then I can jumped in like
the movie being there you gotta do it
you gotta do it Brad I got I mean I and
when I started smoking weed I started
fighting my other buddies that I'd been
friends with at church yeah they were
you know some of those guys would smoke
weed too and so I just I mean some of my
favorite times were just like sitting on
the side of a field on a camping trip
just [ __ ] high as a kite calling each
other gay for six hours just like one
thing I never got into was camping like
that was a big thing people used to do
dude I wasted psychedelics like no I
wasted psychedelics like nobody's
business dude I hear all these stories
but the way people used to do psych it
down yeah like I took shrooms and I went
to the woods man I realized nature dude
I remember the first time I was on
shrooms I was in the maybe not the first
time the first a few of the times I
would go to the beach I do the right
thing right but I remember being on acid
this was when I was on acid I was in the
garden city
tell which is like a high-end hotel on
Long Island and I was on acid and I had
this like dumb little suit jacket on and
I was turning around a guy next to me
I'm like people in Rockville Center
which is another town mm-hmm I'm like
they don't have any [ __ ] money these
people totally like the whole thing was
lost on me it's your grid I like I like
double down on materialism being like
you know where these trails look good
Louis Vuitton like I took the empty it
didn't work I went to the other side I
started telling the aliens I start
trying to sell them like capitalism
I started test selling them timeshare
entities are sitting down well it does
make sense I do like going on vacation
dude the second time I did mushrooms we
were camping at the bottom of a canyon
and it started raining and so it's
literally flooding like we're in the
camper we look at all our shoes have
flowed out with with just this river it
came out of nowhere I'm on sure I'm on
shrooms I go outside I take my shirt off
I take my shoes off and I'm like running
my friends are like you're running to
the top of the hill like spinning around
I'm like we'll be fine like we're gonna
be fine right and then they're like what
we should leave I wouldn't literally
talk to the to the the the trooper there
whatever the [ __ ] they call the guys and
he's like yeah you'll be fine we got a
tarp it was beautiful beautiful I I dug
a channel from like we're camping was
into the natural river soft flow and I'm
just like tell my buddies like see it
all works out guys you're about to kill
yourself you've got a knife at your
throat I think the first time he liked
to turn me off the camping one of the
first times oh I don't want my uncle
Steve and my uncle Steve took me and my
little cousin Brendan camping and it
rained for like 48 hours straight my
uncle Steve we just sat in the tent and
he listened to National Public Radio the
whole time you know and he was like his
country's run by war criminals and I'm
like and later on ironically I was very
susceptible to that message but at that
point I was just like this isn't
where is the toasted marshmallow yeah
yeah where's the that's like your movie
yeah having of Tim Dylan is in that time
in that tag just sitting there one day
all rant about war criminals yeah one
day this will be my life I'll be he's a
funny guy man
sometimes at Christmas he'll be like I
like a little unrest simul and rashes
like I don't want anyone to get hurt but
he's like it's not wrong little lambs
blood on the door we wish you a Merry
Christmas
some people have dark lives I like like
it's one of those things where that's
where my humors dark cuz I knew dark
people mm-hmm I just knew dark people
and we just did the way it was and you
know that's why I laugh at the [ __ ] I
laugh at and I think shit's [ __ ] up
and yeah because you lived a real life
yeah well I live something I mean I live
something we've talked about it the fact
that we were all three of us were raised
in the church like if we were better off
being in dated with just lies but in the
the safety of religion you know as
opposed to yeah when we were watching
you for you we were like yeah odd we
grew up in the church all these girls
are just getting railed out there on
pills they're there they're selling
nudes to pedophiles on the Internet
yeah I mean it's horrific it doesn't it
make you grateful when you watch them no
I want to be selling nudes to pedophiles
honestly yeah well I didn't get to take
that opportunity you know to be like oh
that's a television show like I don't
know my friend's brother who's 15 and he
said they do this thing on Instagram
where they rate the girls well they'll
just post a picture of one of the girls
in the class and all the guys comment
like about their features personality
and would they date or would they not
and the guys will rate like two out of
tens I mean I just she anything to do
but weren't they doing that in the 50s
outside of a diner somewhere yeah right
they just did that on the radio I found
a piece of it I mean I thought you're
gonna say so much worse here that is
shitty shitty to do but that's how
Facebook got started where does he live
Houston I mean I could is it like that
they're like
edie have you talked about the school
shooting [ __ ] [ __ ] are you doing the
drills
no I'm kidding I don't talk to anyone
that age so are they doing drills is
that really happening yes it is yeah my
[ __ ] 9 year old is doing shooter
drills that's daddy you gotta walk in a
serpentine pattern daddy to avoid the
valleys [ __ ] crazy every bleep that
is bleak she also just believes 9/11
happened and didn't ask why the [ __ ] is
wrong with serials you feel dude I'm
talking something man it's because I
vaccinated this into being a sheep yeah
no it's a thank you would you learn 9/11
well what happened people flew their
planes in the other towers hey can i
play a fortnight when I get home I'm
like what did they like to be why hit
happen
no no like interested I remember like
being stoned and having them going they
hate us for our freedom and believe like
believing that right yeah and then like
years later I'm like oh I was so stupid
like I was just taken for a ride like
everybody did you flip on that Tim um
when did you get into conspiracy
theories in general I'd been listening
to Alex Jones since 1999 or 2000 I went
on the gcn Network like I would know
like almost Instagram profile watching D
95 right died for Alex's 99 AJ all day
when did I really get into him I I was
always kind of flirting with them but I
was still not swayed by them until I was
a you know really what got me into them
hardcore when I bit into them for a
while but the financial crisis mm-hmm
yeah cuz when that happened and I
realized how everything was like pretend
yeah like the entire economy was based
on nothing yeah you got to remember that
I was like not like people imagine like
all of us mortgage guys knowing that
this was gonna happen or
no one really did like I was handing my
family out my business card I thought we
were just selling mortgages and like I
bought one of those mortgages and I was
again there a fixed rate for two or
three years and then they'll adjust but
at that time we'll all just refined like
though I was 22 I didn't know and then
when the economy came crashing down I
knew that like we knew we were trying to
make money
we knew that I didn't realize how
everything because every adult every
person I mean I was working for guys
mm-hmm these were middle-aged guys some
of them that had wives and families and
kids and houses and cars and then we
have the president coming on TV and
being like Americans or homeownership
said as high as level 70 percent of
Americans owned houses which everyone
should have went how the [ __ ] to that
what yeah but it was all and then when
that started to happen yeah I started to
realize because I was like well my
parents like my mom went to college my
dad didn't go to college
but I was like all of our parent like
everybody that we know is kind of [ __ ]
mm-hmm but I was like then I was around
all these people are just making all
kinds of money essentially doing you
know selling these mortgages that were
backed by nothing and based on nothing
yeah and then when that whole thing
started to fall apart and unravel I
found myself questioning a lot of other
things and being like well if everybody
was so wrong about this yep and if and
then a lot of people you grow up and you
realize that a lot of people were just
sucking as much money out of the system
as they could before the eventual
collapse but that was what you started
making me think like oh I bet that
there's a lot of other instances where
it's like I started to become very very
cynical yeah about everything after that
happened and I would say I started to
get into the venn and I had been into
them but I just want to started going a
little deeper in them yeah and like how
does the economy work what is the US
dollar backed by you know like
I said you know I started questioning a
lot of those things does the president
do what we all think they do like he is
this Internet has become more
predominant at that point yeah you could
investigate this stuff he's yeah and I
just started reading a lot and then
really the the thing that really got me
was a book called family secrets by russ
Baker that was the book that I read and
I read it in 2007 when the economy
crashed at borders I bought it in Long
Island and borders where I used to jerk
off in the bathroom drunk the California
Pizza Kitchen got hammered and I would
check off the borders bathroom and then
go home like an American like a good
American and I went into borders was
imported noble not--was borders at that
time or maybe it was sold the barn or
whatever and I went in and I got this
book family of secrets by russ Baker
which I really can't recommend enough
and I read it and after I read it I went
okay right now because things started to
make sense to me that didn't make sense
and I'm like oh I get it yeah you think
to yourself feel like how's the bushes
like been in the White House like you
got to remember HW was a vice president
and a president for one term so that's
12 years yeah and his son was a
president for two terms so that's eight
years right so that's 20 years most of
my life there was a bush in the White
House you know doing something and it
was it was interesting to me why I'm
like why is and then all the other books
that came out we're like bushes an idiot
Bush is dumb remember that was all
genres yeah the book bushes a dummy and
he's a cowboy and I'm like yeah but
that's not explaining nothing yeah
anything and this is what we're doing
now a trouble yeah he's Russia
he's our before but to that book open my
eyes to this idea that the bushes were
not masters as much as they were
servants mm-hmm like they are masters
clearly but they
serve a class of people that I'd never
heard of really that I had never done
any meaningful research into this group
of very powerful very wealthy people
that were always kind of behind the
scenes and then I started reading about
things like when FDR was president they
were there was there was there were a
lot of wealthy industrialists in this
country were going to have a coup they
wanted to overthrow FDR really yeah and
there was a general and I forget the
name been like Jamie would have had the
name ready Thanks
he's playing with the dog gonna slap him
around a little yeah now
FDR coup there was a there was a general
that they'd all got behind and and this
is not really taught in history books
you have to look all of this [ __ ] up
right and I forget the guys name
attempted coup against FDR Smedley but
Smedley Butler medley Smedley Butler was
a chap named when they were gonna like
there was all these plans do to like
march on Washington and really yeah take
it by force yeah and it was never really
brought up and talked about and and and
then maybe 20 years later or whatever
you know or 25 years later Kennedy gets
popped yeah
so you start to piece this stuff
together and you start to read about
this and you start to go oh that group
of people really very uncomfortable
democracy on any level even the Republic
they don't want you know anybody being
able to impact their livelihoods and
cost them billions of dollars which
makes sense to an extent when you know
people go well if Kennedy is going to
stop stop us from mining in the Amazon
basin and stealing these minerals or if
Kennedy's gonna make it harder for us to
drill for oil or if he's not gonna if
the CIA is not gonna play ball and
overthrow the government in these
latin-american countries so the United
Fruit can go in there and that's why a
lot of these governments were overthrown
because you know American corporations
multinational big corporations
British corporate in the whole cool when
Iran was BP you know British Petroleum
they were gonna nationalize the oil and
they were gonna you know so if these
government's were not playing ball with
American corporate interest the CIA
found a way to get rid of them yeah well
the CIA found a way to foment a coup in
their own country so when you start
reading all about that [ __ ] you start
understanding you're like well there was
CIA doing this who are they working for
and you're like oh it's the same people
the bushes are working for that same
crew and it's not ten guys in a room and
that took me a while to realize too
because you think oh it's just these
eight guys smoking cigars mm-hmm and I'm
sure there are lots of collections of
eight guys smoking cigars sure but it's
a class of people that's ever evolving
ever changing they don't all like each
other they don't all have the same
interest but a lot of them have very
similar interests in the way Russ Baker
said he's like these people will sue
each other they'll fight each other
they'll take each other to court but if
an outsider
threatens them they will unite
immediately to vanquish that outsider
mm-hmm you know do you buy into this
whole I've been thinking about this a
lot Jews well it's a joke you read my
lot of Christians making money off war
sorry all right
oh yeah and far-left i support israel
never been there don't really care to go
I'm more of a Rome guy I was gonna say
do you I've been thinking about like you
think is social media like it's kind of
like the collective unconscious made
into an actual thing and that
unconscious can now be [ __ ] with in
terms of algorithms and is that like a
way of these elites kind of controlling
the discourse of dude I will tell you
this I don't know as much as I should
about tech and I will say this what I
know is terrifying
yeah what I know is terrifying I think
social media has gotten away from the
elites a little bit - mm-hmm I think
technology's gotten away from them and I
think they're trying to clamp down
because I think it has woke people up a
little bit and it has made it much
harder to pull off certain things like
I've seen stuff all of that we would not
know about Epstein yeah without social
media you'd have no [ __ ] clue it
would be hearsay the major media would
not print it it would be some [ __ ]
Journal it would be in black mother
Jones it would be in some thing that
barely anybody read it would be and
nobody would talk about it knew there
would be no Trump
a guy like Trump whatever you think
about Trump would have not gotten off
the ground neither would a Bernie
Sanders you know because it would have
been shut out you know right do you
think they can like readjust I might be
wrong but like readjusting like just
being like okay let's just track people
while we buy all the water for the
[ __ ] Mad Max times in 20 years they
don't have people to argue about
transgender bathrooms yeah here's the
thing I don't even think that they have
to put that much effort in to
distracting us I just think that pretty
much we've we're rotten to the core
I think it's decades of food additives
drug use pharmaceuticals bad living I
just think it's a steady diet of sugar
carbs fat booze pills [ __ ] ton of pills
[ __ ] ton of pills I think people are
worked to the point where they are on
the edge of a nervous breakdown and then
the the the the art that we consume gets
worse and worse and I mean it just you
know it's simplistic not all of it some
of it's great but I mean if you look at
like mainstream [ __ ]
none of us telling you to question
anything no none of it's telling you to
examine anything hmm
late-night shows are just celebrities
lip-syncing that's what people want oh
yeah I mean where it's talent show yeah
it's it's like an app per hour yeah and
I think my whole thing is I think
Americans know down deep that this is
all built on a house of cards I think
Americans know down deep that it's all
bad and they don't want to they don't
want to look what's behind door number
two I really believe that most people
know that and they either delude
themselves into thinking that they don't
believe that or they just as George
Carlin said every
as a cellphone that makes pancakes so
people get into gadgets and gizmos and
and when you reach a thing it's almost
worse when you wake up and realize how
stacked the deck is against you it's
really hard to imagine that you're that
you're gonna do anything like this girl
greta thunderbird that refuses to fly to
bring attention to climate change it's
like good great whatever but also what
is that gonna do nothing you know what I
mean like I understand that it's good to
wake up the younger generation they're
gonna start demanding things but it's
also like I like the idealism of some of
them some of them it's been misdirected
mm-hmm they directed into the social
justice thing right but let's be honest
how many of these young people are going
to grow up and be in their mid-30s or
their late 20s I'd be like oh I just got
to make money yeah I I don't have the
you know I think Isaac David hog they
went through a tragedy and whatever they
want to be historic figures they want to
be there but you know what starts to
happen man
I remember after reading that family
secrets book and and then I connected
with Raycom later on and he had also
read it but I remember reading that book
and putting that book down and going
yeah you know what yeah they won yeah
you know but it's like the time to
challenge that sit like they like ever
since World War two when Allen Dulles
you know and those guys created the OSS
became the CIA they created the national
security state that created essentially
a secret government that was accountable
to nobody they brought over all the Nazi
scientists
from Germany Operation Paperclip
Operation Paperclip
they we became a superpower we did
certain things to sustain that we became
this major massive economic engine all
of that a lot not all of it but a fair
amount of it was done by our
intelligence community doing some very
nefarious things all over the world and
you know this whole idea was it's just
that fiat currency and the idea that you
know the economy is based on this
perpetual growth model of like having to
keep getting in Wars boom in the bust
cycle this idea that we can't not be at
war we can't not be in a conflict it
won't work like those realizations you
know Tana has a coach who's a writer he
said I said a lot of things I've I think
are a little much but he's a very good
writer he said once about these dollar
cheeseburgers he's like somebody
somewhere is paying for those dollar
cheeseburgers like the fact that you can
drive up to a restaurant pay a dollar
and get a burger that was made for you
yeah
for a dollar through a window someone
somewhere is paying for that like our
lives are artificially subsidized by a
lot of terrible things and you start to
realize that and you're like ooh this is
no good you know him but also you know
not to sound cliche but it's like what
do you do nothing really nothing you can
do it because it's like this is now you
can do good things you could do charity
you could do this you could do that you
know people developing countries like
Rogen those cool things invest in like a
clean water project and all this [ __ ]
there's things you can do but when you
look at this system this didn't happen
yesterday it didn't happen because of
Trump this is a system that's developed
over a very very long time and in order
to change that like it's gonna collapse
under its own weight slowly but it's I
don't think it's ever gonna look
substantively different from the thing
that we know hmm
other Oertel just be worse
but it's not gonna like it's not a turn
around and become like right it's a
probably a lot more boring than we want
it to be
yeah well it's it's everything like runs
Baker said it he's like it's not just
it's everything it's the military it's
every element every part of our society
looks the way it does because it
developed in a certain way
and to really unravel this whole [ __ ]
you know being drunk on cheap credit
putting all these wars on credit like
all of these things to unravel this
massive scam yeah and you know it's
almost like now it's like the secretary
at Enron being like you know we should
really make good and somebody cool you
shut up her mouth yeah shut up it's too
late too late
you ate the [ __ ] shrimp cocktail you
got the company car you went to the
[ __ ] hotel you went to the sales
conference and then you saw a
documentary you didn't like yep or you
made a documentary Chelsea and I'm not
saying totally black pill and totally
don't do anything but like get a [ __ ]
clue mm-hmm before you just start
spouting off because the people that are
spouting off like well once we get rid
of Tron
it's gonna be okay once Lizzy warns in
everything but no it's like no y'all go
back to sleep you'll just go back to
sleep you'll just go okay things are
good now you know oh we have the first
trans Secretary of Defense sweet right
yeah yeah I mean it is what it is man
Epstein's dead
the guy who accused Kevin Spacey's dead
they all really as Jake Paul would say
it's everyday bro everyday bro
with that Disney Channel flow and you
know yeah how long have we done we got
to wrap this our 27 oh that's song you
start speaking in a Chinese voice
yeah at the end of the day you know and
you know some people might say that's
misguided but it gives you a moment of
joy you know what I mean
such dishonor yeah but I mean you know
you do you make a documentary called hey
privilege it's me Cho you fix it up and
and you do what you gotta do but it's a
great book Ben has it downstairs he's
not read and he begged for it I gave it
to you thank you very much I will try to
read it soon
what do you mean try can you read I
don't understand try to read it I have
the audio help version if you want it if
you read any of it
yeah yeah how great it's [ __ ] amazing
dude it's very it's uh it's just it's
just a constant because it would be very
easy to listen to it and be like all
these guys are full of [ __ ] right but if
you pay attention because the I mean
like Bush being there at the [ __ ] JFK
assassination and they break it down to
where you're going okay this makes sense
it's answers a lot of quite a lot of
these logical answers yeah we've
intended rush three times on patreon to
you could find the episodes rush Russ
Baker
oh it's rush limbaugh he'll rush Bo the
MA rush a place to drive around Long
Island just [ __ ] coked out listening
to rush my chevy suburban i could barely
afford to put gas in just a 44 gallon
bath and he went away for oxycontin
addiction he came back and his first
show back greatest starting his greatest
opening everywhere was on now where was
I
but that's what we want
it was spectacle yeah yeah yeah it's a
beautiful piece of energy I think it's
gonna beep you do believe that there's
something beautiful about the end you
know those your cat dancing around with
the Hat oh you know many of our
musicians and celebrities now are
clearly mentally [ __ ]
so they're promoted people have gotten
behind and just pushed to the front of
the line you know that Billy is a young
generation into it's like they like this
girl that bleeds from her eyes and
dresses up you know it's like oh good
but what would they be into think about
what would they be into right did you
for you a good show by the way I hate it
it's fun to watch but it's not good it's
pretty [ __ ] yeah it's a it's like The OC
do you ever watch that [ __ ] it's those
waters Laguna Beach which was the
reality show same same type of thing but
I mean this is an actual but you know
you watch it and you're like this is a
piece of sh isn't there a scene with a
bunch of dicks in it there's a billion
dicks there's a big dicks it's yeah it's
a show of dicks that's why it's called
about high school kids which is weird
but they're older yeah it's not played
by like 17 year olds but it's a lot of
16 year olds getting 818 to play younger
right the fantasies still alive yeah the
best show on TV right now the best two
shows are on HBO they are berry in
succession yeah I like succession a lot
yeah a succession is yeah I guess curve
is still on get curves great yeah but
what I love about succession is that you
know against everything we talked about
mm-hmm it's a lot of that stuff and you
watch it and you're like yeah this is
this is who's controlling the
information that you got mm-hmm that
those are the you know media is very
weird media is a real bloodsport there's
like five or seven families that own
these media conglomerates and they're
insanely brutal and they all go with
each other and they plant stories about
each other in the press and you know
it's you know the Murdock's were one of
them not to like successions based up
there's also like the Sinclair family's
the red stones that have a Viacom
there's like a bunch of them and
especially media in New York in New York
is like the media capital of this
country in the world really but
certainly this country
those families had an insane amount of
power when just determining what you saw
and heard you know these people
determined what you sat down and read at
your kitchen table every morning and
that's shaped what you cared about yeah
or what you thought was important and I
do think succession is one of those
shows and I'm not usually a guy like
this it's the girl it's important show
but I do think you could look back at a
show like that and go well this gets it
pretty right right like this gets it
pretty right about you know these really
power crazed power-hungry Titans them
that control news and information in the
way that that intersects with politics
and business and Brian Cox is amazing I
think it's one of the best cast shows on
TV
a hundred versus great every character
is great even that a retarder game plays
like cousin Greg is fantail he's great
Greg is one everyone loves and an actual
[ __ ] [ __ ] again hi I'm so dumb why
can't it be if we're done now dude it's
a good show if you haven't watched
succession folks mm-hmm well that same
[ __ ] gaunt going conglomerate [ __ ] that
is where they can control everything
that's why Facebook is such an issue as
much yeah that's what most people are on
to do everything well that's just a new
that's like meet the new boss same as
the old boss you know those guys are now
controlling what you see with you but I
do think that the problem is now this is
reason why everyone throwing insane now
we know it's so [ __ ] up and more
powerless yeah yeah before you didn't
know his [ __ ] it wasn't in your face now
it's in your face now they kill Epstein
right in a Cell now you're starting to
go 9/11 why did building say I don't
understand fire like a lot of people are
starting to wake up dude dude I remember
9/11 conspiracy conversations you used
to be shunned yes yeah if you brought
that out and now if you bring it up
people like yeah man what do I know do
when Epstein
like we don't know when episode went to
jail Jase was like glowing for like
weeks yeah it was a great cuz you know
what I thought everybody was gonna
apologize for treating me like a dumbass
at a party when I was going off about
Epstein I think it was gonna I remember
me and Malin did that podcast right
after it came out and we were like
there's nice in the neck I was like
there's no way anyone faces any
consequences he's like no not at all
yeah - but I thought here's what I
thought was gonna happen I thought they
were gonna come out they pin it on like
two congressmen that got massages and
they didn't even do that
no nothing even that black book is
sitting in an evidence Locker
they're not gonna declassify any of
those documents I think they dismissed
everything and you hear a Tom Hanks bot
is a state is that true yeah which
should stay the epstein estate not
little st. James
no no not little say James which one in
Manhattan yeah from from everything well
that that I've heard of yeah check that
out yeah yeah I'm Hanks for Jeffery
Epstein's townhouse in Manhattan Tom
Hanks a pedophile they'll be pretty
great I mean the America's Sweetheart
like you know I was in every movie when
we grew up
ever since big he's been raping kids I
mean it's hope you find something cuz
otherwise it's just like Kevin uh claims
Tom Hank it's so weird bye listen it's
probably probably got I did a good deal
but it's a weird buy apparently he did
fly on the loot Lolita Express but I'm
not finding yeah I don't know I think
that might be a rumor because I've seen
people say that but I haven't found any
news article I also think you know a lot
of time like people money but on that
plane and Epstein wasn't on it like him
and I don't know um but I think maybe
that was a plane that got loaned out to
Chelsea Handler at dinner with him
that's a fact Tim I hate to say it but
that's why we need the Donald because
there there were some good stuff that
was dug up on there like when we were
looking into those GOP lawmakers that
were that were killed in June
yeah that's why we met at Donald Trump
what have you found anything out you
conducted an investigation into that
woman who was killed if you found
anything out I mean she was definitely
it you know what it is she was she had a
bunch of information I supposedly she
had information that was connected to
Epstein through the CPS as well in the
state of Arkansas don't know if it's
true but they get he was get Arkansas
CPS kids for the presidents of Fox soup
what the hell's going on I don't know
man I mean you know a lot of this stuff
is just all linked I mean you know how
it hurt Tom banks actually killed her he
lose go mess with Kevin just throw a Tom
Hanks cut Kevin off in traffic the other
day [ __ ] how was that you know I
heard Tom Hanks that's the rumor on the
street you know it'll come out yes she
was passing bills to get c-class truck
drivers to be aware of sex trafficking a
man that killed Nancy Schaefer that
they'll just kill you the thing is so
stupid
I mean you're elderly Christian
grandparents shooting each other in the
head yeah time that's what happened
right they had a bad fire from the
Cracker Barrel but this is why
everyone's going insane now because you
can look this [ __ ] up and you know it's
[ __ ] you know in your heart and in your
head
you go this is not good and it's still
like just yeah then you just turn to
nihilism so yeah you did you just turn
to complete nihilism which is why I
think we have to fight that with radical
self-promotion hey man that's what you
have to do like instead of giving up on
everything you have to believe but only
in yourself right start doing stand-up
doesn't matter if you can sing doesn't
matter if you're funny to stand up if
you're 400 pounds be a model none of it
matters
you're creating your own reality to live
in that's a good time about find a new
diet start an Instagram page for your
cat do whatever you want to do lose your
and little things and make them the big
things make the little things the big
things you know yeah I mean that's the
move I keep a juicy juicy like the booty
booty he liked it plump I got I got
hired to help produce the guy's podcast
and he's like talking about what he
wants to like make it about an
inspiration what not and then at one
point he goes you know maybe I'll just
get a bunch of chicks with big tits to
get in a hot tub with me Ryan it's it's
and me and Ben were talking about it
just like yeah this guy's like this the
yeah idiot genius he said to me he's
like people are [ __ ] [ __ ] so you
can't make them think so I'm gonna have
guns and flamethrowers and gold chains
and cash and girls with big fake asses
and big fake titties I'm gonna blow up
my Instagram I was like yeah it's like
yeah he's a genius that's a smart move
yeah that'll work
we'll end the episode where we sat down
the day with a guy and we said you know
this does your cat video where she goes
[ __ ] I'm a cow [ __ ] I'm a cow I'm not
a cat I don't send me out [ __ ] I'm a
cow and then she goes moo moo and she
puts french fries in her nose got fifty
four million views mm-hmm and I said to
somebody I was you know that's weird
mean better faster better [ __ ] cuz I'm
like so we make these videos like we
tried it to all the stuff is topical and
funny and has a good angle and he goes
yeah what you just said you try that's
your first mistake
you try nothing could make less sense in
this world
then try you almost want to smack as
soon as I said it I wanted to smack
myself in the face and be like I'm
trying what kind of [ __ ] lunatic
tries plug all the social media guys
plug your podcasts brain jail podcast
yeah I'm podcasts and YouTube channel
yeah we got a 360 VR camera going for
our episodes you guys are the first view
our pod hundred percent one ya like it
yeah
at brain Jail pot or uh at brain Jail
pot at gmail.com yeah if you want to
send us an email I am at doji cat on
Instagram now I'm at Tim Jay Dylan di
llo on Instagram and Twitter you guys
know that Tim de la comédie calm we're
updating the site in the next day or two
with dates you have a lot more live
dates coming up people are starting to
buy tickets go out to shows please I
have a new hour of material if you see
me before you will not hear any of the
same jokes come out it'll be fun I'm oh
I almost have a new hour material but
will you care I'll do proud work for the
rest of it I'm almost there I think I
got a good 40 that I really like and
nowhere to put it
nowhere to go put it on YouTube nobody
cares yeah captions on it shut er down
I'm a cow I'm not a cat I don't see me
like if let's see you brought like
Mozart back and showed him that like if
you showed any of these people that they
would be like oh this is for children
right they'd be like oh this is like a
for kids that's kind of I don't know why
you're using the word [ __ ] but this
isn't chart this is a chart it's like
how much the popular culture with just
previous generations if they came back
and watched it think was for children oh
yeah like emos oh you've goofy outfits
and you jump around your child right yes
but kids shark is literally for kids
there's not much of a difference between
baby shark and I'm a cow right it's the
same stuff [ __ ] I'm a cow I'm not a cat
like don't say meow do we have to just
get a giant inflatable ass to put behind
the dust videos that just jiggles it's
not the worst idea we just gotta find a
way I think we got to find a way to to
try to make them a little crazier just
hire to do two models and just have him
shake their ass at Tim's face yeah well
here all he does I'm Megan McCain video
and maybe just get throw some hogs in
there you know I'm sure we do do what
should we do what about Chelsea ham I
talked about that dumb documentary I
mean that might be a funny angle
as Chelsea Handler no I can't keep
dressing that much I would just do it as
a guy where I'm like what I really like
about the documentary about it she
doesn't talk to that many black she
talks to a white guy in her backyard
which i think is that's how to get to
the heart of it that's right then she
goes and visits a boyfriend she hasn't
seen in 20 years and this poor guys been
in and out of jail she shows up with a
film crew you see the huge salted
pretzel with mustard all over it I just
think it might be funny to just call it
out for being kind of bananas right you
know [ __ ] no desk anymore no desk I
think just you sitting at a big fake ass
just right there with the ashtray in an
ass I like Stan you know he's inside
just has to go places I think the desk
has to go to locations yeah straight now
yeah well I don't know dude maybe go
back to just like there was some
brilliance in the early things it was
just me on a topic but it didn't have
the costume it didn't have you know that
Lena Dunham won but we had Isis marching
yeah yeah well I wouldn't say no the
amount of times you guys have called me
down at like 2:00 a.m. to show me a
video we're like and you're like an
Indian's getting his head cut off behind
him is can we get away with this I'm
like maybe I think it might be funny be
like I just saw the best new documentary
it's called hello privileges me Chelsea
Chelsea Handler's a comedian that wanted
spent our entire career examining these
types of issues you know it's been an
entire career examining these types of
issues what I like about the documentary
she doesn't talk to a lot of black
people it's mainly her interviewing a
white guy in her back yard and then she
visits a black guy that she used to bang
who's been in jail for 10 years and then
she shows up for the first time in 20
years with a film crew mm-hmm there's
just something nice about that just like
boy I'm glad I killed that baby like
it's just something nice about that man
it made me really think this is the
change I want to see in the world you
know
hello privilege it's me Timmy yeah I
just want no racism but also no black
people that privilege was a black shirt
Chelsea thought she was gonna interview
a black chick named probation Chelsea
thought she's gonna interview somebody
named privilege all right folks
beautiful up your membership spend more
money on this patreon cubed spoiler we
deserve good bye bye